[Music]  if you think about this the speed at  which a crisis develops far faster than  it ever did before and so you may not  have all the information you would like  you may not know all the facts and if  that might lead you to not respond you  know there's a natural tendency well we  don't have all the facts so we can't  really say anything well what you can  say is what your values are and what you  can talk about your values and that  whatever you do in response to a  particular crisis is going to be based  on the values of your organization or  your company companies that don't really  have clarity about their values and are  kind of coming up with them on the fly  they're at a tremendous disadvantage  conversely companies that have a very  clear sense of who they are what they  stand for even in the midst of crisis  they have competitive advantage  [Music]  you